I want to jump to the story from the
Daily Mail controversial group behind
the trans day of Vengeance raised money
for firearms training as other trans
protesters pose with guns ahead of March
in DC on Saturday now I want to make
sure I State this uh first and foremost
they have a right to Firearms they have
a right to firearms training and I do
not care if they want to go and March
peacefully while armed that is Second
Amendment right and in DC they don't
allow it which I think is wrong however
we just had a mass shooting
where a transgender individual wrote a
Manifesto these people defended it and
are now calling for a day of vengeance
this is as close to the line as you can
get they're standing on it just to be
clear the president United States
tweeted out the other day
when with respect to uh his court
hearing that people should go out and
protest and the left went nuts and said
how dare he call for protest with
respect to you know his this decision
that make him down about uh you know
from from the Manhattan district
attorney these folks are talking about
firearms training and I agree with you
they have a constitutional right to do
all of the aforementioned
but no one on the left they were they
went nuts and apoplectic that Donald
Trump was calling for people to protest
full stop just the word protest these
folks are talking about taking up arms
getting firearms training and no one on
the left seems to say a single word you
need to stop assuming you are in the
same country as these people they know
they hate you they know you are not a
part of their plan and their system so
when Joe Biden hears about Christians
being shot he laughed he laughed and
said I don't know anything about it you
know anything about it right nine three
nine-year-old children were gunned down
and he says I don't know about it and
they said Josh Hawley thinks they were
targeting Christians he goes well then I
probably think that I probably don't
agree yeah and I'm simply and I'm joking
yes I mean I'm joking about a tragedy
that six people just got killed like
that's I'm not sure what what's the
worst part about what you just said I
want you to imagine it this way
um what's your favorite sports team Sean
the New England Patriots New England
Patriots have they played against
anybody recently or what's what's the
most recent uh game they played well it
would have been last season last season
yeah uh name another team you don't like
the Jets the Jets and they play against
each other I'm not big on Sports It's
both in the AFC East all right all right
so uh um tell me the tell me the teams
again it's the Patriots versus the Jets
Patriots versus the Jets so you are
watching the Jets
get get uh was it football yep they get
through a touchdown and it's a
controversial call are you gonna cheer
for them no not for the Jets exactly and
you're going to be angry and outraged
but let's say there's a controversial
call that benefits your team are you
going to defend them
no of course I mean the benefits the
Patriots Yeah it's a controversial call
it's not like it's definitive one way or
the other you're gonna say my team
should get it sure and then when they
get no no no no I'm gonna challenge that
what's happening right now in the United
States is that
the Democrats have been doing this for a
long time they they will uh Joe Biden
for instance will engage in a quid pro
quo with Ukraine saying if you don't
fire the prosecutor not getting a
billion dollars when we say hey you guys
broke the rules they start laughing you
think we're playing a game with you we
don't care about that we can get away
with whatever we want but we will wield
those tools against you that's what
they're doing so unfortunately for us
the refs are on the Jet's side right now
oh yeah the refs the commissioner the
corporate response I mean that's the
thing is it's one thing to say the refs
are with you they got the league they
got the corporate sponsors they got the
guys who build the field and so when you
are sitting there and they keep throwing
out controversial calls and giving the
other team the touchdown
conservatives Independence and and
disaffected liberal types Libertarians
just keep going oh come on ref well you
know we'll get them next time what are
you talking about they're all laughing
behind your back these protesters go out
to the home of Supreme Court Justices
illegally you can't do this and Merrick
Garland says do not arrest them
and then you get some woman who took a
picture in DC on January 6th they raid
her home in Alaska even though she
wasn't in the building
this has been going on for some time
pro-life pro-life activists get their
homes rated these people get protection
I I'm telling you I just I
I see I don't see it going any other way
it is happening right before our eyes we
hadn't we had in Wisconsin these BLM
activists set fire to a house twice
and then when that same group showed up
in front of another guy's house he
brandished a firearm inside his house
feeling threatened and the police came
and arrested him oh I know this is they
went into his house and took him and the
BLM activist cheered for it they cheered
for the police I think the the thing
that folks on the right have got to
start understanding in my opinion is
that this idea that that there's a that
to I mean this goes to exactly what
you're saying that somehow that we've
that it's a Level Playing Field and then
we've just we've got to start playing by
their rules and and saying fine then
we'll go out and fight and like this is
where we've got to defund their like
everyone wants to play nice and nice
right so for example right now the
Republicans are going through this debt
ceiling thing why are we not defunding
everything on the left this idea that
somehow it's got to be a like let's play
nice with them and figure out we control
the house the house controls the first
string start defunding things stop
pretending that this is uh that we need
to get along and get along they they do
fun stuff on the right like this is
there are some this level of
collegiality that we believe that
they'll treat us like like if they get
back in power that's just never gonna
happen but but so the challenge I
suppose then is
if if this is the direction everything
is going regardless of what we want to
happen What happens in five or ten years
here's my point if we don't recognize
what you're talking about that the fight
is on that they are going after they're
going in I mean I was at this Library
this morning to talk about
wholesome things about patriotism about
being a good person right and the
library a DC Public Library put up pride
and trans flags all over it right to
that was their counter
like I saw those photos right and this
was like we weren't there to I there was
no anti-trans anti-pride there was no
this wasn't about any like any message
that was against anybody it was
literally here's a message about being a
good person there the fight is on we
either are willing to to go out there
and and engage
or they're going to win I kind of looked
at what they're doing right now is overt
acts of violence death threats terrorism
in Atlanta they fire bombed a government
facility they burn down houses they
burned uh I flipped over a guy's truck
and conservatives are barely mustering
up speaking events Matt Walsh was forced
to cancel a speaking event over death
threats meanwhile they are calling for
violence this weekend they're out there
look at this
firearms training I mean they're going
out there doing this and not one media
organization will report on this tonight
Hunter Biden takes what 1.5 million
dollars and and we get and people on the
right get accused of making up stories
well there are but my point is Hunter's
a prodigy painter of course well he does
those are very beautiful but the point
is is that at some point
we've got to start understanding that
that the corporate media and everybody
else they're not going to give us a fair
shake so go out there and and stop
pretending this idea that I mean I saw a
story today on the way here Chris
Christie won't support Donald Trump if
he's the nominee stop it do you think
that they said that when John Federman
was the nominee in Pennsylvania or Joe
Biden was the nominee this is this idea
on the right that we're all this purity
test give me a break I'll vote for any
Republican that's the nominee to go
against Joe Biden there is I mean stop
this nonsense I I just think
it doesn't matter what we do
the millennial and gen Z generations and
younger are hyper-radicalized
hyperpolarized and the only thing
stopping overt and direct conflict is
that Gen X and boomers are still in
control at the highest level of
Institutions but we've got a good 10 or
20 years left before they're not and
then when you get Disney run by woke
leftists and their entire world view is
solidified and they think you're a Nazi
we're already seeing what happens with
Merrick Garland in control of the doj he
says protect the people breaking the law
that benefit us and prosecute those that
even step anywhere near the line that
oppose us yeah so where are we going to
be in 10 years going to be worse well it
depends on what you do for the next 10
years if I I think we should not firstly
do not engage people in violence
directly because that's like there's
this metaphor fighting an alligator
underwater you don't want to fight it
under the water yeah don't do that do
not fight them in a place where they
want you to fight them in it's not the
way but I always spent like four hours
last night listening to music and
realized again for the first time again
that the key moving forward is to create
the culture is to make massive Ripple
effects and inspire people and make
people come together for something other
than
hate something other than stress and I
think that's the way forward I think the
most powerful thing people can do right
now to try and reverse things and and
protect this country is start a business
make money have a family
get some chickens maybe get away from
cities I think the family and money
thing is the most important it's Mike
cernovich who's been saying this for a
long time because if you plant those
seeds right now you build personal
wealth you build a business you have a
family in 10 years we won't have to
worry about the levers of control can I
just make one point though because you
know you call that my age here I uh I
don't want to speak for Hannah Claire
but I mean as a father as someone here I
assume like I
I I sit around sometimes with parents
and all all their kids will have phones
and I'll be like they're like oh you
know these kids with the influences and
I'm like you're the one who handed the
kid a phone yeah you're the one who put
the kid on Tick Tock don't tell me that
you're upset about the influences that
your kid have you let them have Snapchat
you let them have Tick Tock you gave
them a phone and now you're complaining
I'm sorry my kids are 12 and I don't I
didn't give them a phone I don't allow
them on Tick Tock and I think that at
some point be a parent yeah I think the
phone argument it's the phone it's the
Kindle it's the iPad it's the TV I said
this one's on the show but I think
having a TV in your home is like asking
a stranger off the street to come
babysit your kids right especially cable
TV you don't know what's going to come
up on anything you don't know what uh
video YouTube is gonna put on next after
the one that you put on for your kid
that you think is innocuous you don't
know what any of the algorithms that
your teens are looking at is going to
generate for them and that is so
incredibly dangerous but Tim you you
you're talking about you know having a
fan family and going to a farm I mean
but part of this is and I agree with all
that right but in some cases it's it's
possible in some cases it's not but I
would say regardless of whether you
could move out and and you know get a
piece of land which is I think a lot of
people would love to do it but some
cases it's not possible but when not
engage with your kids find out what
they're learning I mean the one great
thing about covid is that kids sat at a
kitchen table in a lot of cases and
parents said this is what you're
learning this is what you're reading and
they actually were able to have some
discussions but I just you know I I I I
think that too many times YouTube is
substituting for a babysitter or
substituting for parenting or or your
neighbors I think that the core the
family is the nuclear building block of
society right but you should know your
community as well right that's one of
the reasons I love coming into an office
I know the people I work with I know
what's going on with their life I think
we could all be better about knowing
what the other people on our street or
in our building I mean you're right not
everyone can move to a farm but you
could know your neighbor if you could
know them better you could build a
relationship with them especially if
they are the people living next door to
you right it's one thing to follow in an
influencer because maybe you're
interested in something they're working
on whatever else but you can't let those
parasocial bonds uh replace the Real
Life Connections you can have with
people thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time